من جانبه قال المتحدث باسمي وزاره الدفاع
الالمانيه ديفيد هلن بولز ان العرض
المقدمه الى بولندا بنشر بطاريات باتريوت
على اراضيها وتسير دوريات المقاتلات
الالمانيه في اجوائها مازال قائما ياتي
ذلك على خلفيه رفض برلين طلبا بولنديغن
بارسال منظومات الى اوكرانيا
الى بولندا
التي تمثل حدودا خارجيه لحلف شمال الاطلسي
ودعمها في مواجهه التهديدات خصوصا عند
سقوط الصواريخ على اراضيها متابعوا الان
من كتب المناقشات التي تجري في بولندا
وتسيير دوريات للمقاتلات الالمانيه
قال وزير الخارجيه البريطاني جيمس كريفري
انه بريطانيا تدعم اوكرانيا بالافعال وليس
بالاقوال فقط تصريحات وزير الخارجيه
البريطانيه كليفر لجات خلال مباحثاتي في
كييف مع رئيس بلديه كما بحث كليفر لي على
هامش الزياره مع رئيس الوزراء الاوكرانيه
مصادره اصول الروسيه المجمده وسعادتها من
اجل تعافي اوكرانيا كما قال كليفرلي خلال
لقائه نظيره الاوكراني ديمتري كوليبا ان
بلاده تقدم ما وصفه بالدعم الملموس لدفاع
عن اوكرانيا